as I understand Focus protection let the  virus spread among the population don't  disrupt the economy don't disrupt  anything let it spread among the less  vulnerable and try to protect the more  vulnerable that's what I understand  folks production it's not a question of  let open schools is a good example are  we letting the virus spread when we open  schools no we're letting school happen  the virus may or may not spread  Focus protection are  policies that are cognizant of who's a  high risk and moving resources Ingenuity  and creativity to protect those  populations anything that does that is  focus protection